Continuing
where we left off last night
in the verses of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
introduced us to an individual who was
of the chief antagonist
of the prophet sallall.aii
Alw
and Alwira.
He is the father of most notably
Wit. As a matter of fact, he had lots of
children.
Some historians
mention at least 10 while others place
them at around 13.
And close to half of them are confirmed
to have become Muslim
in spite of their father's insistence
on disbelief.
So much so that he would constantly
threaten his children
with regards to believing in Islam or
following the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. He was noted to have
threatened his children constantly
that if you become Muslim, what they
referred to as the time at the time in
their language was
mean meaning.
If you follow Muhammad and embrace his
religion, then you will not get any
portion of my will and I will not
continue to support you.
So in doing this he
really affected the choices that his
children made. And this is perhaps one
of the reasons that Khaled Wid himself
only became Muslim way later, just
before the conquest of Mecca in the
sixth or seventh year after Hijra, after
the battle of after the battle of
Alb.
And so this had a big a big effect on
the people around him. He would control
people with his money, with his wallet.
And as we mentioned yesterday, his
wealth was not just a source of pride
for him. It was his identity. He was
known to be the most wealthy man in
Mecca, one of the most wealthy men ever
in the Arab Peninsula.
And so his wealth was a very touchy
subject to him.
And Abu Jahel is ali's
nephew.
So Abu Jaham,
he is the nephew, the paternal nephew of
Alw.
And
as was reported by Alakim and others,
Abb
tells us about an incident
in which
Ali Mur's fate was sealed.
Alw Mur had plenty of chances to change
his ways.
He remained the most staunch enemy of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam from
the first year of his prophethhood until
the day he died three months after
hijah. So that's how many years close to
14 years
he made his choice time and time again
to fight against the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and the Muslim and he
spent a lot of money doing that
and he
seduced with his money a lot of
people away from Islam
in order to take them to hell with him.
But when did this all start? What was
the first moment when his fate was
really really sealed? These are the
verses in surah mud
that mention to us the first time when
he initially made that conscious choice
to disbelieve in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to disbelieve in the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam and to actively
fight against Allah and his messenger
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
forch.
[Silence]
In these verses, we get the first moment
that you can almost the way Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
relates to us the details
of him making this decision. You can
almost see the gears in his in his mind
moving to figure out a way
to reject the truth but maintain his
position as a man of justice.
That's a very precarious thing to
balance, isn't it? to reject the truth
in one hand but then claim to be a a a
a vanguard of the truth in the other.
This is what we call cognitive
dissonance. This is what we call
compartmentalization
as psychologists would call it and that
is that a person starts to lead two
lives at the same time. They have two
faces. One face they talk this out of
and the other face they talk this out
of. When those two ve faces occur, that
is the moment that the person reached
his crossroads and chose to go left.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us of
this moment in great detail. Ib Abbass
sheds a little bit more light on the
context of these verses.
He mentions that as was customary the
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
would
sit at the haram and as we've
mentioned before the Kaa and the
masid around it right where people would
make
this is where the chieftains of Mecca
and the different tribes would have
their ni their nedi a nadi is is
a place where they would meet it's
a hall right And each tribe had
their own medus around the Ka and the
major chieftains and the tribe leaders
would go and they would sit there and
people would come in with their
different issues or whatever it is. This
is where they would meet and spend most
of their time. And the prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam would come
there to the haram and he would pray
at the ka there and he would try to
talk to whoever was there whoever came
through go to the different noadi around
the ka recite the Quran any new verses
of the Quran that were revealed he would
recite them on the chieftains there he
would try to speak to people as they
were in talf and sometimes he would just
sit there and wait for people to come
and sit down and listen to what he had
to say.
And so on one occasion
we have the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam sitting as was customary
there and reciting the newer verses of
the Quran.
And who was spotted in that gathering
but al
spotted in that gathering
sitting there listening to the Quran now
because many of us even the Arabs
amongst us we grow up speaking Arabic
but we're speaking about an Arabic that
is 1500 years ago not only has the
language changed but the context of the
langage language has changed and the
environment of the language has changed.
And so now when you want to understand
the Quran as the prophet and his
companions understood it, you have to go
out of your way and dedicate yourself to
the discipline of learning that Arabic.
It's not just something you're born
with. Nobody naturally speaks that
language anymore as it was.
And that's the way that languages are.
They evolve. They develop as different
civilizations interact with each other.
But the Arabic language has been
particularly pres preserved by the
scholars of Islam because of its
critical nature and relationship to the
Quran and Sunnah. You can never
understand what Allah and his messenger
said unless you understand not just
Arabic but that language that they spoke
and you know as the language changed
even the different tools or different
daily things that they had we don't do
these things anymore and so the names
for those tools or those things also now
doesn't mean anything to us. We didn't
grow up using those things. So the
scholars of Islam at at certain points
would even draw images
of these different tools.
Just this is a side issue but
to show you the meticulous
detailoriented nature of the scholars of
Islam. Iban Hajar is an 8th century
scholar.
Iban Hajar mentioned a narration
that had a term in it that basically was
a backscratcher. You know it is a back
scratcher. You ever see that wooden
thing that's shaped this at the top
and you use it to scratch your back? You
know what I'm talking about, right?
Certainly not an issue. H how is that
important?
Because that word was no longer used in
his generation. He researched it and
drew a picture of what that back
scratcher looked because of this
one very obscure narration that mentions
this back scratcher. And he said because
I feared that this word would be lost to
the Muslim and they would not be able to
conceptualize what this word means in
the narration. This is the detail that
we're speaking about.
And so if a person wants to understand
really how captivating the Quran was,
it is hard for it. it it doesn't have
that same it doesn't elicit those
exact same emotions and it doesn't have
that visceral
effect even on Arab speakers unless
they have learned that Arabic language.
The Quran in the time when it was
revealed
was so eloquent, so visceral, so
surreal, so jarring
in its vividness and so uncanny
that the people of Mecca used to hide
their children when the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam would walk down the
street for fear that they would hear
some of those verses.
It was so eloquent and so incredibly
surreal and vivid and frightening to
them that Abu Jahi and
others of the chieftains of Mecca
used to leave their house and hide at
night and wait for the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam to come to
pray at night as he would do at the Kaa
and listen to the Quran
until the break of dawn.
This is how captivating the Quran was to
them. I mean, we are Muslim and you'd be
hardressed to find many of us that would
spend every single night to the break of
dawn hiding to listen to the Quran. Abu
Jah used to hide behind the cloak of the
Kaa, standing up against the wall of the
Kaa all night just to hear the Quran.
Abu Jah.
And so this is the effect that the Quran
had. who was seen in that gathering
listening to those new verses.
And when
came back to his nadi, to his gathering,
he said to the other chieftains,
[Silence]
He said, "I have never heard words like
that before.
It has such a beautiful veneer on it and
it has such a sweetness to it. I don't
want it to stop."
He said the top of it is just fruit
after fruit after fruit and its bottom
is deep and visceral
as if he were describing a tree.
He said
this is this is
saying this. He said, "I swear that
these words are the highest words I have
ever heard and no one can hope to beat
these words. I don't know where he's
bringing this from."
And so he's talking this and he's saying
this while he was still kind of
jarred by just having listened to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam recite
verses of the Quran.
And so he left. Abu Jah came his nephew
and the other chieftain said, "It looks
your uncle W is getting ready to
become Muslim." I mean, he came and he
gave us this big speech about how great
the Quran is. It sounds he's
starting to lean to towards that.
And so Abu Jahil said,
"Leave him to me." And so Ib Abbas tells
us that Abu Jahil
being the cockroach that he was, he knew
exactly how to push his uncle's buttons.
And so he went to his uncle. Remember
the most wealthy man in all of Mecca.
A man who's not only finds his wealth to
be a source of pride, but his wealth is
his identity.
Abu Jahi knows that and he understands
that weakness about his uncle's
character.
And so he went to his uncle and he said,
"The chieftains
and the tribe leaders were just speaking
that they want to pull some money
together to give you as a stipen in your
old age."
He said, "Qores knows I am the most
wealthy man amongst them. Them give me
money." He said, 'Yeah, because it seems
that they're under the impression that
you're starting to listen to Muhammad
because he offered you some money and
maybe things aren't as strong in your
financials as we thought. So maybe we
wanted to get some money together for
you. You're so old and take care of
you."
And this perked him right up.
He said,
He said knows that I am the most wealthy
amongst them. What an insult to say such
a thing to me to even to even assume
such a thing. Of course, they never said
that. Abuja had made all of this up.
And he said, "Well, if that's the case,
I mean, they're confused.
So, you should come and give a final
answer.
to the chieftains and to the youth and
really take a staunch clear position so
that nobody is confused anymore because
everybody seems to think that you've
become Muslim.
And so he said, "Okay, let me think
about what I'm going to say."
And so this moment
when he was to go and say what he
believed or say what his pride was
driving him to say. That was the
crossroads.
Same thing with same thing with Abu Jah.
Every one of us, every human being
reaches that crossroads where you make
that one choice and it changes the
direct the trajectory of your life
entirely.
And so
he as Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
that he started to think what am I going
to say?
What am I going to say these words are?
Because for us to say that the Quran is
from Allah,
this answers the questions. But for a
person to say the Quran is not from
Allah. This raises many more questions
than it does answers. You can't just
deny it and think it's going to go away.
You have to explain then where did it
come from? And so this was the position
they were in. If we're going to deny
this book and take this position against
Muhammad, we need to figure out what
we're going to say as to where this book
came from. And that is what he was going
through here. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said
he then looked off into the to the
distance thinking
and then he kind of frowned and furred
his bro his brow furled his brow
and then he said Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said
that he then at that moment decided to
reject the truth and turn away from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and he came
and said
he is not a magician because we have
seen all kinds of magic and this is not
any of that. He is not a poet
because we have heard all of the poetry
and the best of poetry and it is not in
any way similar to that. He is not a
madman because these wisdoms cannot come
from a mad man.
He is not a liar because we know him for
all these years.
The best thing for us to say is that
he's a magician in the sense that he
divides between a man and his own son
and a mother and her own child because
they saw Muhammad as a troublemaker
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. We were all
united and loved each other as big
family and then this man comes and now
fathers and their sons aren't talking to
each other anymore. Now he's dividing
us. We need to unite, not divide with
each other. This man is bringing nothing
but trouble and division to our ranks.
This is what they believe. This is what
they were saying.
And so he said,
"And this is most similar to being magic
or this is most similar to be something
that he's being taught by someone else,
someone that's not here. Someone is
using him. He's not a liar, but he's
being lied to."
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
that his conclusion was
this is magic that is being inherited
and passed down from some ancestors who
are magicians.
Bashar. This is actually the words of
some other beings or some other people
that are not amongst us. But we know
that he's not the one who is
manufacturing these words.
This is a very critical moment that
Allah documented in the Quran. And why
did he document it? Because as we said,
never read the Quran and look at any
verse as being a verse that is for
someone else.
If you're reading the Quran that way,
you're reading it wrong.
Every single verse of the Quran has some
application to every single one of us.
When you read the verses,
you look at these verses, you understand
them, and then you think, how does this
apply to me? Do I have an element of
in myself? What part of me is a part of
the spirit of
that that needs to be drowned out from
my ego, drowned out from my behavior,
drowned out from my attitude that
has this is why Allah documents these
things in the Quran. We will continue
this. We've gone way over our time.
All
subhanahu
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.